- You're from Texas.
- Texas.
- Oh, and Doris Day movies, that's right.
- I love Dor, yeah.
- Did you?
- I love Doris Day films.
Yeah, Rock Hudson.
- Really?
- I saw the "Pillow Talk" and
I saw those when I was a kid.
- Yeah, I love them, I was obsessed.
When I'm sad, just so you
know world (giggling).
When I get really sad.
If you come in my house
and you see me looking at "Pillow Talk,"
if you see me watching "Pillow
Talk," just leave the house.
(laughing) It's not going well.
(laughing) That's my thing I
turn on to just like pep up.
- Makes you feel good.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- Do you have a movie like that?
Please say Jurassic Park
or something of yours.
(audience laughing)
Please say like, well, my own work.
- Well.-
That would be amazing.
- I do like The Wizard of Oz.
- Oh, me too, me too.
- And I'm not supposed to talk about it
but I just worked with
your friend, Ariana Grande.
- Oh yeah (gasping), yes.
- Because she's in "Wicked," you know?
- [Kelly] I know.
- Along with Cynthia
Erivo and Michelle Yo.
And I'm in it, anyway, I can't
say anything more about it.
(audience applauding)
- I'm gonna love it.
I've seen the actual production "Wicked"
maybe seven to 10 times.
I don't even know how many.
- Really?
- Yeah, I love it, I kept
taking different people.
- I took my kids, and
Emily, this last time
in London where we shot.
And I was crying
throughout the whole thing.
If you know that show, it just kills me.
I had seen originally with Idina Menzel
and Kristin Chenoweth, and
it just kills me, that show,
- All right.
- I'm excited.